et on va plus loin tout de suite avec
vous Marianne pierza des bonjour Mariam
on vient de le dire vendredi mazalinski
qui se félicite d'une bonne nouvelle des
renforts sont donc enfin arrivé
exactement livraison qui fait suite à
une annonce la semaine dernière de Joe
Biden le président américain lorsqu'il
avait reçu le président ukrainien à la
Maison Blanche alors pourquoi c'est
livraison arrive plutôt que que prévu
car on va rentrer dans l'hiver il va y
avoir des températures extrêmement
basses en Ukraine et ça devrait ralentir
l'avancée donc de la contre-offensive
ukrainienne mais Joe Biden lui aurait
aussi promis autre chose la livraison
domicile longue portée dit
atacm S qu'on va voir derrière des des
missiles qui peuvent avoir une cible à
300 km et qui peuvent être tirés depuis
le sol cela a été promis lors d'une
visite à huis clos à Washington mais
divulgué par certains médias américains
donc aucune confirmation de la Maison
Blanche pourquoi ça reste secret parce
que 300 km ça permet d'atteindre en fait
le territoire
et ça pourrait être considéré par Moscou
comme être co- belligérant mais ce que
demandent aussi vos leadersky s'en
relâche à chaque fois qu'il rencontre un
chef de l'État ce sont des avions de
combat des avions access car ils le sait
la défense anti-aérienne russe elle est
faible comme en témoigne les derniers
tirs de missiles sur la Crimée sur
Sébastopol vendredi dernier on va y
revenir donc il demande des avions F16
il en voudrait environ 120 et l'Ukraine
en dispose pour le moment d'une
quarantaine à noter que les États-Unis
sont parmi les premiers contributeurs de
l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine depuis le
début de la guerre donc le 24 février
2022 Washington a envoyé 43 milliards de
dollars d'armes à Kiev voilà une annonce
qui intervient dans un fort contexte de
tension en mer Noire exactement depuis
le début du mois de septembre les
Ukrainiens multiplient les actions et
les prises d'abord les prises de
plateformes de forage dans le nord de la
mer Noire ou encore des stations radars
qui étaient utilisées en fait comme des
bases arrières d'espionnage et de
renseignements pour de surveiller
justement l'activité ukrainienne en mer
Noire ce qui les a affaiblis justement
puisqu'ils n'ont pas vu venir ils n'ont
pas pu empêcher une attaque de grandes
ampleur si elle est confirmée par les
Russes la mort de Victor Sokolov un
amiral russe de son état major lors
d'une grande réunion au sein du quartier
général de la flotte ruse de la mer
Noire c'était vendredi dernier ça a été
annoncé hier ce serait la perte la plus
importante la perte du plus haut gradée
depuis le début de la guerre donc en
février 2022 parce que ce que vise en
fait l'armée ukrainienne en ce moment
c'est la flotte n'avale russe qui se
trouve en mer Noire elle la vise par les
airs l'armée russe qui a perdu plusieurs
croiseurs amiral notamment et la Russie
qui a une impossibilité de changer ou de
remplacer son matériel puisque les
détroits Turcs seul point de passage de
la mer Noire sont fermés au navire
militaire depuis le début de la guerre
donc on voit bien que les Ukrainiens se
concentre sur cet objectif pour aussi à
obtenir des nouveaux corridors en mer
Noire pour vendre leurs Céré ales et ça
a marché puisque deux cargo chargés de
milliers de tonnes de céréales ont pu
quitter ces derniers jours les portes
ukrainien merci beaucoup Mariam pierzade
ce